on continue d'examiner l'état de notre
économie si le pays est moins dépendant
qu'on aurait pu croire des matières
premières c'est beaucoup grâce à la
multiplication d'entreprise qui innovent
et qui oeuvrent dans des secteurs très
pointu mais aux quatre coins de la
planète
c'est le cas d'une société montréalaise
luhmann pause qui s'impose de plus en
plus comme un leader mondial dans le
domaine de l'éclairage
maxence bilodeau le jour tous les
édifices sont gris la nuit certains
distingue parce qu'ils sont illuminés et
en couleurs une tour à calgary un stade
à vancouver partout au pays des édifices
et espaces publics prennent vie grâce à
la lumière croix du mont royal pour de
l'horloge casino de montréal
musée d'art contemporain maison
symphonique
ils ont tous en commun d'avoir un
système d'éclairage conçu et assemblé à
montréal chez nous mais on pense
il ya un engouement définitif au niveau
de la mise en lumière urbaine c'est
clair quand une nouvelle place publique
on a envie d'y aller quand y'a un
spectacle qui arrive en ville on a envie
d'y aller quand on met en lumière nos
lieux nocturnes
on a envie d'aller s'y promener le soir
dans ses locaux du quartier griffintown
à montréal lumengo rassemble des
systèmes d'éclairage qui n'existait pas
il ya dix ans ce sont des lumières fait
avec des diodes électroluminescentes les
tél la nouveauté c'est que ces diodes
sont maintenant assez puissante pour
éclairer des édifices entier le coût
d'achat est certes plus élevés mais les
dell consomment beaucoup moins d'énergie
et durent beaucoup plus longtemps que
les systèmes d'éclairage traditionnels
le canada c'est vaste mais c'est un
petit marché l'importance de
l'exportation l'importance du marché
monza le marché québécois marché
canadien c'est nettement insuffisant
pour vous nous on est déjà 80% de notre
chiffre d'affaires qui est exporté à
l'extérieur du canada et du québec
donc pour nous c'est capital les airs
sans ces marchés là on serait jamais
capable de développer l'entreprise qu'on
a aujourd'hui
new york luhmann force à utiliser plus
de 700 lumière pour illuminer le in the
building sur park avenue londres
éclairage du musée victoria and albert
heijn suède un centre de ski en couleurs
est aussi un pont le pont solvès borg
en passant des ponts à montréal c'est
parce qu'il passe le bonjour 4 iso de
temps c'est certain que rolls comme tous
les ponts nous tendent des édifices à
éclairer dans le monde ils sont nombreux
et tout ce temps nous mènerons à bien
l'intention d'avoir sa part du gâteau
l'entreprise a aujourd'hui un chiffre
d'affaires de 100 millions et près de
500 employés
la croissance se fait par la conquête de
nouveaux marchés par l'acquisition
d'entreprises et aussi c'était il ya un
an par l'entrée en bourse pour amener de
nouveaux capitaux
c'est vraiment un véhicule de
financement accéléré c'est la capacité
d'avoir une monnaie des changes
lorsqu'on va tirer du talent lorsqu'on
veut faire des acquisitions stratégiques
et c'est très difficile d'avoir un maire
véhicule que ça la recette du succès
c'est une combinaison d'ingrédients dont
voici le plus important chez l'homme and
poor's il faut s'entourer des meilleurs
un sac à main cela ça prend beaucoup de
rigueur pour réussir en affaires faut
avoir une vision pour comprendre où est
ce qu'on veut aller il faut surtout
admettre qu'on peut pas y aller seul
fait que ça prend les meilleurs faut
jamais lésiné sur les meilleurs talents
les meilleurs talents
voilà leur idée la plus lumineuse